hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about future of Science
and Technology let's see I see we have a
whole bunch of questions
here
uh we have a question from time what do
you think is more which do you think is
more likely teleportation or time travel
you know I think I've talked about both
of these topics uh a bit before but
let's talk about them again um uh a bit
well time travel there's time travel to
the Past there's time travel to the
future you know if we could solve
cryonics figuring out how to you know
like freeze humans we'd have great time
travel to the Future just like you can
think about you know every time you go
to sleep it's kind of like time travel
to the Future you are thinking about
your day and you are sensing the passage
of time through the day and then you
don't sense the passage of time until
the next morning and we can certainly
imagine and people think thatth I mean
this the problem of of cryonics is uh
one of those things where basically if
if you could just get a biological
organism down to the temperature of
liquid nitrogen then all the sort of
processes that normally go on all the
sort of biochemical processes that
normally go on would would effectively
stop and the thing would be in kind of
suspended animation until it's uh heated
up again the problem is when you cool it
down bad things happen in particular
water has this very nasty feature that
ice is for a given volume of water ice
is bigger than the liquid water and so
you cool things down if if they freeze
then to ice then and and since the the
majority of what's in US is water that's
the a lot of the content of our cells is
water that means that if you cool us
down to uh so that we are um freezing
then um uh the um
um uh then then um uh then the problem
is that all of the water in our cells
expands and that destroys our cells so
the question is can you get from the uh
kind of the normal body temperature down
to the temperature let's say liquid
nitrogen um uh you know without that
happening and there are all sorts of
ways people think about doing that there
are cryoprotectants basically
antifreeze uh chemicals that um just
like you put salt down on on roads and
things and that reduces the uh the
freezing temperature of water you can
try to do the same thing the only
problem is you got to get that
antifreeze into every cell in the body
and that's not easy to do our
bloodstream carries uh things like oxy
into every cell in our body but it's not
so obvious how you how you carry these
other other chemicals in there or you
can try some kind of more physical
process of you know higher pressure or
maybe the electrical magnetic field
something like that but my own feeling
is there hasn't been an awful lot of
there's been sort of people have been
picking away at this problem of cryonics
for a long time and it's been kind of a
field that people don't don't take
seriously my guess is it will eventually
just be solved and it'll be figured out
how to take you know a biological
organism including any of us and just
say okay uh put it on pores you know
freeze it down to liquid nitrogen
temperature um and uh let it hang out
there for as long as one wants and then
kind of wake it back up again so in a
sense that's time travels to the future
if you say okay I'm I'm going on pause
now you know maybe I've got some medical
problem that can't be solved today but
in 50 years I'm sure it's going to be
solvable you know just pause for 50
years or even five years so that's
that's in a sense experiential time
travel to the
Future when it comes to time travel to
the past it doesn't make a lot of sense
because the the the universe evolves and
the way the universe evolves according
to the UN the rules the universe evolves
according to and if you said
take my thread of experience and have
that loop back to the past it it doesn't
really make sense you can you can create
something where you have what in sort of
physics is usually called the closed
timik curve a curve where sort of the
the progression of the future goes back
to the past but what does it mean when
you do that well anytime you have a
system whose Behavior repeats you
effectively have it
in a closed Tim like curve for example
let's imagine you have an oscillator
that's just going back and forth back
and forth back and forth okay the the if
that if that oscillator is the whole
universe if there's nothing else in the
universe or nothing else that you care
about in the universe then for practical
purposes the future of that oscillator
is also the past of that oscillator
because the thing has it's gone one to
one side then it's going to go back to
the other side and so on it's the the um
the the one can think about its future
as returning to the state that it was in
in the past which will then continue to
be its future and so on so normally when
when people say oh you know there are
all kinds of paradoxes that you get into
or what if I went back in time and
prevented myself from being born what
would then happen well the answer is if
there there is a an evolution of the
universe so that the that you could do
that then in a sense what's happening is
you're just defining sort of a
consistency condition that this happens
in the universe then this happens then
have that having happened this now has
to happen it's it's kind of this Loop
like the case of the harmonic oscillator
and some kind of oscillator where
essentially something where the behavior
is just rep repeats repeats repeats
that's kind of like time travel that's
the best you're going to get for time
travel to the Past any other kind of
thing where you say well I'm making a
decision to travel to the Past doesn't
really make sense if you believe that
the Universe evolves according to
definite rules your decision to travel
to the Past sort of already was included
in what happened in the past and you you
uh the best you can do is to have this
kind of consistency Loop go on
so let's see now let's talk about
teleportation and first thing to Define
for ourselves is what do we mean by that
we mean we're here and sort of a moment
later we're somewhere else and normally
we expect that the speed of light is the
thing that limits how fast anything can
travel in our universe what does the
speed of light talk about the speed of
light says that if you want to go a
certain distance in space it's going to
take you at least a certain amount of
time or uh and and so now there's the
question is can you can you break out of
that let me let me comment on a couple
of different things for practical
purposes if we're sitting here and we
want to find ourself ourselves on the
opposite side of the Earth the the even
if we could do that at the speed of
light we would be very impressed that
would be very useful and obviously we
can do that with information we can take
uh some you know this this live stream
is going out to all kinds of corners of
the world through uh fiber optic cables
and things like this and it's going at
something very close to the speed of
light so the informational content of
this live stream is being ported quickly
at least to to lots of other places so
we'll talk about in a minute the
question of of um uh sort of things
going very fast like at the speed of
light as compared to at the speed that
usual material objects travel at um but
there's a separate question which is can
you make something that goes faster than
the speed of light that's a different
issue that's relevant if we want to you
know get to the other side of the Galaxy
u in in a human lifespan or something we
bet we we're going to need to go FAS
than the speed of light so the question
is can can that be achieved that's a
separate question from the question of
whether we can take material objects and
have them go at some speed very high
compared to the speeds that we can
normally get you know planes and Rockets
and so on to go at let's talk about
going faster than the speed of light so
as I say the the main issue is in a
given amount of time how much of space
can you cross
and that's actually a pretty subtle
question because it depends on the
structure of space if for example in in
so we've known for a hundred years that
sort of space is not quite as uniform of
thing as we had imagined there can be
curvature in Space the presence of mass
produces curvature in space that's what
leads to gravity and in the case of
something like a black hole we have more
extreme kinds of curvature in space
there are weird kinds of things that can
happen in space for example there's this
idea of a wormhole where essentially one
place in space is directly connected to
another place in space and you can kind
of go the long way around or you can go
through this kind of Wormhole this
handle where one piece of space is
directly connected to another piece of
space there's a question of can we make
a wormhole like that well in traditional
theories of gravity and theories of
SpaceTime it's really difficult to make
a
wormhole if you if there existed a
wormhole if somehow in the beginning of
the universe a wormhole was created it
could have been with with with great
effort it could be
sustained and what would it mean if it
was sustained well it would mean that
you kind of go across space one way and
it takes you 100 years or something even
at the speed of light you go across
space the other way you kind of go in a
slightly different direction in space
and you go through the Wormhole and it
takes you only a second for example to
get to the same destination so it's it's
what's happening is in that case space
is multiply connected there's more than
one way to get from one place to another
and by the way it's it's so so but
that's something that's very hard to
create in traditional theories of of the
way space time
works it
um uh in our models of of of space and
time and so on things are a little
different because the structure of space
is itself
Dynamic and the the the the the whole
sort of the network of little atoms of
space that make up the structure of
space that's a very Dynamic thing and
much more Dynamic than it is in
traditional theories of gravity and so
on
okay so the following tricky thing can
happen if down at the level of kind of
atoms of space there's a lot of sort of
apparent Randomness in the way that
things are getting connected and
disconnected and so on and the question
is can you somehow cheat that Randomness
to find a way to get from one place in
space to another sort of more
efficiently than by the the the than by
sort of going through the usual
experience of traveling through space
okay so let's take an analogy uh
molecules in a gas in a room these
molecules are randomly colliding with
each other the typical molecule goes a
millionth of a meter before it collides
with another molecule and every time it
collides it's it's direction is more or
less randomized and the time it takes
for a single molecule to go across the
room can be quite long that's why for
example you know if you if you open
something that smells has an intense
smell on one side side of the room it
takes a while for that smell to diffuse
to the other side of the room that's
because the molecules that are the thing
that create that smell the molecules of
that smell of that scent are they're
they're in they're in the air and they
keep on getting they're going in One
Direction but then they get bashed by
another molecule they go in another
random Direction and they're kind of
randomly uh walking from one side of the
room to the other quite slowly the
actual molecules in air for example go
pretty much at the speed of sound and if
if you could only figure out how to
attach yourself to exactly the right
molecule instead of diffusing across the
room if you could jump from one molecule
to the next and get exactly the right
molecule every time you would be able to
sort of surf across the room at the
speed of
sound okay so why can't you do that well
you can't do that because you even if
you were down at the molecular scale
it's still hard to know which molec to
pick and it's very computationally
difficult to work out which molecule
should you pick now then the next time
and so on to be able to do that
surfing this is why the the things like
the second law of Thermodynamics work
because you can't sort of untangle you
can't figure out how all these sort of
apparently randomly moving molecules
even though they actually do have
definite rules for how they move you
can't kind of figure that out in advance
to see how to kind of untangle the
randomness
but if you could you would be able to
kind of surf from molecule to molecule
and get quickly across the room okay why
is this relevant to space time well it's
the same kind of story because these
discrete elements that represent the
atoms of space at this very small scale
they too are interacting in the all
these complicated ways of of having uh
of it's not like collisions like
physically moving it's rather the kind
of network of relations between these
things is continually up updated if you
could only know exactly what was going
to happen you could kind of attach
yourself to a certain atom of space and
you could be surfing across the universe
and you could be uh the the the kind of
the overall structure of space is
defined by sort of the the aggregate
sort of random behavior of all these
atoms of space and in a sense you can
cheat the usual rate at which sort of
things are connected other things by
doing this kind of Surfing process the
only problem is you fundamentally can't
do that because you need you would need
to be able to work out computationally
what's happening sort of you be able
have to be able to outrun the universe
to know exactly where you should go next
in order to kind of surf these these
atoms of space so the fact that you sort
of can't go in the end faster than light
is more of a sort of engineering problem
but a very fundamental engineering
problem then it is some something
actually about the structure of of
SpaceTime now one of the other problems
is that even if you could do all the
surfing and so on the problem is what
could you sort of get through the
universe faster than light the answer is
it won't be you because you are this
great big you all of us are these great
big things with you know 10 to the 100
atoms of space in us and we are this
this sort of coh
object that successfully moves from one
place and space to another when we move
it's a it's a complicated thing that
motion is possible that you can take
this whole big object that's us made
from one set of atoms of space at One
Moment In Time and then at every
successive moment of time we're made of
different atoms of space and the fact
that there is this connection between us
at one moment of time and us at another
moment of time in another place
potentially
that's a non-trivial fact that this that
pure motion is possible that we can
maintain the coherence of us as entities
through time and in different positions
in space it's kind of the analogy I tend
to use here is little Eddies in water
you know the the you can see this Eddie
and it maintains its its coherence even
as it moves through the water even
though it's made of different water
molecules at every successive moment of
time so the question is does the physics
work out so that we can maintain our
objectness as we move through through
time and as we move across space and
it's a fact that we notice that yes we
can maintain our our objectness as we do
that pure motion is possible but now
when you start kind of trying to mess
with things down at the level of
individual atoms of space and you're
trying to cheat sort of the structure of
SpaceTime then it's no longer going to
be the case that the thing that can
cheat the structure of SpaceTime is a
thing that can also be sort of a
material object like us so my guess is
and and this is something which one can
sort of prove at the same level that one
can prove the second law of
Thermodynamics law of entropy increased
from computational kinds of ideas
something I I just recently wrote a
whole book about um the uh in that same
sense I think one can essentially prove
that a material object like us can't go
faster than the speed of light only a
thing that is deep shredded so to speak
has that possibility and even that isn't
really possible for something that is
computational embedded in the
universe
so okay so the only way one could get
sort of faster than light travel in the
universe is through some some structure
like a wormhole or another kind of
concept that I sort of talked about a
couple of years ago is things called
space tunnels the universe doesn't have
have to be completely threedimensional
in our models and so there could be a
place in the universe that is let's say
five and a half dimensional and that
place when when you have higher numbers
of Dimensions one one thing that that
means is that there are more ways to
connect two points than you knew before
and so when you have this sort of higher
dimensional piece there can be this kind
of faster this kind of tunnel through
space that kind of connects different
parts more efficiently in a different
way than than that happened and
wormholes but we have no reason to think
that space tunnels exist maybe space
tunnels were created in the ear Universe
because we believe that the Universe
started kind of infinite dimensional and
only kind of gradually cooled down to
three-dimensional and so maybe there are
space tunnels left over from the early
Universe the likelihood that there's a
space tunnel that's aligned with being
in a place that would be in any way
useful to us seems very low so that that
doesn't seem like a thing all right but
but let's take the the different branch
which is how about you just take
yourself and at the speed of light or
close to the speed of light You Move
Yourself somewhere else so the way that
that would happen for a material object
is something we certainly don't yet know
how to do but if we could take sort of
us and we could kind of scan us and turn
us into pure information so to speak so
let's say we had a a device that could
like dis assemble us you know atom by
atom it picks off oh it's this atom it's
this atom it's this atom and you could
take that that sequence of atoms and you
could just describe that the positions
of all those atoms just as as
information so to speak then you
transmit that digitally to somewhere
else and then you essentially have a 3D
printer that's reassembling the object
from its atoms now you could also
imagine that you could scan the object
on one side without disassembling it
without taking it apart without
destroying it and then make a clone of
it on the other side and and that's more
what typically happens with with kind of
Digital Data is like you're transmitting
it but in principle you could keep a
copy of it at the place where it started
so now the question is for and it then
becomes a more complicated sort of
philosophical Consciousness type
question the question is if it's a
question of transporting us there's
there's different things let's say you
want to transport uh I don't know a uh
but say you want to transport a a metal
Bolt from here to somewhere else well
you can kind of almost already do that
you can almost already teleport such a
thing you scan it on one side and you 3D
print it on the other side and although
it takes a while usually to do the 3D
printing let's imagine that that could
be made quicker because I don't think
there's anything fundamentally that that
limits that at least at this kind of
level then effectively you have a
teleportation system for a bolt now the
issue is even if we could do that for us
with all of our complicated molecular
biology and so on what would happen to
our thread of Consciousness when we get
tele teleported it's kind of like the
time travel case we could imagine that
we sort of go to sleep and wake up in N
years um and it's still we still feel us
at the other side is that also possible
with with Motion in space it seems much
less plausible it seems that the thing
that would be the reconstituted US so to
speak will not have that same sort of
thread of Consciousness that we have
sort of being in one place going through
time so to speak now then of course the
question arises if at some point in the
future we are uh kind of uh you know
there's an uploaded version of us where
sort of the future of our Consciousness
really is digital then it's a quite
different story and then teleportation
as well as cloning copying of that thing
become much much easier now an
interesting thought experiment might be
imagine that you have boy this is where
it gets complicated imagine you have
some kind of neural implant that has
sort of taken a large part of the of the
kind of um uh the memories of your of
your brain and put them in digital form
and it's going to replay them to you on
neural demand so to speak well you can
take those those outsourced digital
memories and they are very transportable
and you can put them somewhere else but
now the the thing is and this is this
kind of relates maybe to questions about
in a scenario where you've got a brain
and a lot of its functionality has been
taken over by digital
digital stuff to what extent is that
still the same brain the still same
Consciousness and so on and I think one
thing one realizes is if you say well
can we transport it somewhere else yes
we can transport the Digital Data but
there's still that leftover thread of
kind
of I don't know humanness or something
that is still represented by the
material object that is the brain and is
a different problem to be able to
transport but I I tend to feel that um
uh you know we just have no idea what
what it would be like what it sort of
feels like to be a digital Consciousness
that's being transported around to
different places uh we we just have no
uh it's just so different from our from
our normal experience that it's hard to
know uh kind of how to how to map what
one thinks into those kinds of things
let's see all right there's various
comments on this
um
uh
um let's
see okay there's a question here from
Alexandre uh commenting on accurately
reconstructing the past using present
data and
um how much of the past can you learn
from what is there now you know I think
the progress of archaeology has been an
interesting lesson in this regard it's
kind of like could you imagine that we
know you know what was the meal that was
eaten by uh people at the funeral of so
and so and then where all the eating
utensils were buried uh along with so
and so you know we might have imagined
no way are we going to know what that
meal was but then there's kind of
molecular scale archaeology where it's
like well there's a little tiny piece of
DNA that got left over here and we can
reconstruct oh that was a type of sheep
and so on in other words the molecules
tell a story I've often wondered whether
solid objects tell more stories than we
know so for example when you have
something like a
gas there it's really hard to DEC code
sort of what happened you put some some
scent or something into into gas into
air it spreads out it does it to Recon
to to reverse that process this is a
whole second row of thermodynamics story
to reverse that process is truly
computationally
infeasible but let's imagine we have a
solid surface let's imagine it's the
keys on our keyboard and we've been
typing typing typing away on those keys
every time time we type atoms move on
those keys now atoms are moving all the
time just because at at the temperature
at room temperature there's a certain
amount of motion of atoms and atoms in a
solid are always bouncing around a
little bit they're usually kept more or
less in place otherwise it wouldn't be a
solid otherwise it would be flowing like
a liquid or or like a gas they're more
or less kept in place that's what
defines it being a solid but you know
every time we type on our keyboard for
we're moving a few atoms around and the
question is whether it will be possible
in the future just as today we can go
back and do this sort of molecular
archaeology and say oh there was a DNA
molecule left over there we know what
happened will we be able to see the kind
of micro scratches and the pits and so
on of all of these solid surfaces now we
can we can trace the positions of atoms
in a solid surface an atomic Force
microscope for example can trace the
positions of individual atoms in a solid
surface but it's not a very quick thing
to do and if we were to trace kind of
all the atoms in our keyboard uh and the
surface of our keys and our keyboard it
would take an absurdly long time with
current technology but I can certainly
imagine a time when you can kind of do
sort of flash Atomic force uh U
microscopy and just kind of you know in
a moment kind of get the complete story
of where all the atoms are just to give
an analogy for that
in the case of reading of of
uh uh Gene sequencing DNA sequencing for
example uh one it's it's it is
remarkable that uh in modern techniques
like these um nanopore techniques where
you're kind of dragging a DNA molecule
through this through this kind of
chemical hole and every time you and as
you drag it depending on which base a
TCG is kind of being dragged through the
hole a slightly different signal is
produced so you're kind of doing it
little group of atoms at a time and and
being able to read out this DNA molecule
that's again a pretty sequential process
there were other ideas people have had
for how to do Gene sequencing that
involve things like laying out the whole
DNA molecule and the using an electron
microscope to essentially get an image
of that whole DNA molecule
and then kind of examine the image to
figure out what the sequence was but the
question is can you take a solid surface
and by some technique kind of take that
surface and say oh we got a terabyte of
data you know flash we've now got a
terabyte of data of the positions of
lots and lots of atoms it's more than a
terabyte that you need to know where all
the atoms in the keys of your keyboard
are but let's say that you can get just
a terabyte of data it might very well be
the case that in that terabyte of data
you could go back and decode oh I must
have typed the following password on my
keys or whatever um just by looking at
the sort of the way that the atoms move
around now I think if you ask the
question by the time sort of lots of
atoms are interacting with each other I
think one is dealing with computational
irreducibility and it's really hard to
go backwards and to deduce what the past
was but in cases where it's really just
a question of it was a solid thing but
it got perturbed by some action that
took place I think it's quite possible
that one will be able to figure out what
that action was and I I really I do tend
to think that the the sort of the future
of generalized Archaeology is to be able
to reconstruct a lot of the past from
anything that's solid in other words
it's uh those things which are just you
know we speak the words into the air so
to speak we're not going to be able to
reconstruct almost certainly we're not
going to be able to reconstruct how
those molecules flowed around and you
know ancient Babylon somebody was just
talking so to speak and the molecules in
the air no way we're not going to be
able to reconstruct that but if the
molecules in the air caused some atoms
in some sand or something to move around
in some particular way then maybe in
that solid object there will be
something that could have been preserved
just as the configuration of atoms in
the tablets that got you know baked in
the Sun and so on from that time got
preserved let's
see ah evangelos comments we're
definitely generating a germ Factory on
our keyboards we should use it that's an
interesting point that not only could
you probably say uh you know I'm sure
from our fingers there are uh you know
we're we're dropping well even sometimes
uh skin cells but but we're dropping
some molecules and things and yes you
probably can say this keyboard was
touched by this person look here's their
DNA more or
less
um let's
see
uh boots comments there's more than one
way to get from one place to another
that's what gravitational lensing is
doing when light travels a multiple
paths to us yes that that's correct that
there's that whenever you have so in
gravitational lensing it's it's like a
like a like a lens for made of glass for
light where you have two light rays that
you can go from a source and then to
different places on the lens and then
the lens is focusing the light and so
these different rays of light so this is
what happens on our retina all the time
there's a particular object somewhere
you know that I'm looking at across the
room light from that object spreads out
and goes in lots of different directions
those you know light hits my eye the
lens inside my eye the the light that
hits at the top of the lens and the
bottom of the lens the lens is focusing
that light so it's making the light that
comes from the top of the lens and the
bottom of the lens be focused in one
spot on my retina and that's why I form
an image of that that thing that's
distant and yes it's it's the same story
with with gravitational
lensing
um okay p uh Pepe is commenting that uh
wouldn't there be ambiguity many
different possible motions of molecules
would prod produce the same pattern on
the sand well that's an interesting
question my guess is that that wouldn't
happen my guess is that this is one of
the sort of things that we kind of an
intuition that we get from Computing let
me give you an example let's say you
take a uh you take lots of files that
you put on your computer and you say
let's make a hash code from these files
let's take the content of these files
and let's make something that's
128 256 bits long that is something we
get by using some algorithm to just sort
of grind up the contents of these files
and just say give me a
256bit sort of signature of this file
and we do that by grinding up the
content let's say we take the the
numbers that represent the characters in
the file and we multiply them by primes
and we add them all up and we take the
result mod 2 to the^ 256 or something
like this we do some some sort of
mathematical uh weird grinding of the
data that makes a hash code that is that
is a let's say a 256bit code that's
supposed to represent this whole file
now you might have thought no way will
we be uniquely able to tell the
different files on our computer but
actually you can there are it's it's
very common to have a hash hashing
scheme that sort of randomizes things
enough that two files that are different
that you happen to have on your computer
have a very high probability
overwhelmingly high probability of
having different hash codes if if the
hash codes are different then you know
the files are different it could be that
that two different
files if if if the hash codes are
different the files are definitely
different if the files are different it
is still conceivable that they could
Collide and that they could both have
the same hash code but the point is
that's incredibly unlikely so for
example if you have a 26 bit bit hash
code very common length that's used in
practice the probability
that those files will be different files
but will happen to collide and have the
same hash code it's pretty close to 2
the^ minus
256 which is um about well what is that
maybe uh well the chances are if we were
if we were running a computer running
our computer for the whole history of
the universe the chance of us and we
were generating hash codes at every
cycle of our computer's clock we
wouldn't generate uh and and we were
generating them sort of at random the
the were we generating them from
different files the that Collision would
be very unlikely to happen in the whole
history of the universe so in a sense
what that's telling one is that if in so
far as what you actually observe is sort
of some hash code of of what happened
you you're it's it's very likely you can
decode what happened from that sort of
fragment of information it's um the the
possibility that two things were
different and happened to give the same
outcome is is lower than you might think
I I suspect so my guess is that in the
case where you you see this
configuration of of you know pieces of
sand or something that somehow got baked
or fossilized or whatever else my guess
is that there will not be much ambiguity
now now having said that here here's the
way this works there will be
configurations of
molecules that in the air for examp
example that would have two different
configurations of molecules in the air
that would have both led to the same
configuration of particles of sand but
the point is only one of those
configurations molecules in the air is
plausible to have been produced by
somebody talking I mean this is kind of
the the story of lots of things done in
modern times with machine learning that
it's kind of like well here's a set of
things that are possible but only some
of them are plausible given given the
way the world typically is so let me
give an example of that let's say that
uh we have an image of uh of a scene
it's just a two-dimensional image the
question is can we reconstruct the kind
of three-dimensional depth of the
objects in that image well there are
maybe we even have um there there are
there are many possible sort of depth
maps you could get but only some of them
are consistent with the way objects
typically are I mean if we see a hand
hand in that image we kind of know that
the typical hand has fingers that have
ends of the finger and bases of the
finger and you know pieces of the hand
and so on we we kind of know how the
hand is set up and although in principle
those pixels given certain aspects of
how that how they work could be
connected in different ways because we
know it's all part of a hand we know
that the depth has to go the particular
ways they
go uh
let's see yolder is commenting are the
recent studies from MIT that try to make
hash collisions on purpose absolutely
that's uh there are there are that's
that's one of many I mean there are all
kinds of computer security issues I I've
often said so in in setting up lots of
kinds of things in the world there's
this idea of universal unique
identifiers uu IDs and you know we use
them a lot in Mor from language we just
say going to generate a uu idid and
we're going to we're going to assume
that it's
Unique and I've often thought that the
whole technology infrastructure of the
world would kind of start to crumble if
uu IDs started to collide but it's very
unlikely that would happen now the
question is can you game things so that
for a particular system you can force
uuids to collide if you do all sorts of
terrible things can happen and that can
give you some kind of back door to try
break into to some system and so
on okay other questions
here
um let's
see
uh let's see Aon
asks will a web browser ever have a
native runtime for a lang other than
JavaScript EG Python morm language
Etc you know I have to say the fact that
browsers are sort of becoming the
operating system on in which lots of
things operate is a very bizarre turn of
events in the history of computation or
history of practical
Computing there was a time long ago talk
about history early 1980s when
workstation type computer computers
first were coming into existence and
there were two different ways people set
them up they're actually associated with
two different companies with sort of uh
uh particular type specimens for these
ways to set it up Apollo computer and
Sun Micro Systems and Apollo had the
idea we'll build a Windows system and on
top of the Windows system we'll build an
operating system that's kind of a little
bit how browsers are working you build
the Windows system with all the
graphical user interface and on top of
that you build the operating system in
which programs operate Sun Micro Systems
have the opposite point of view they'll
build an operating system Unix operating
system in their case and on top of that
you'll build a window system okay so
what happened at the time is sun
succeeded Apollo failed and the reason
was that an operating system is much
simpler than a Windows system and so sun
was able to build something which is a
pretty solid foundation on top of which
there will be a window system system was
kind of flaky but Apollo on the other
hand had this pretty FL flaky very very
complicated Windows system that had all
the flakiness of a very complicated
piece of software and they were trying
to put an operating system on top of
that and that didn't work very well well
now we're you know 35 40 years later and
we're basically trying to build an
operating system on top of a Windows
system in the case of browsers and the
uh the fact that there are sort of trans
compilers from uh from um languages like
C++ into JavaScript is just bizarre now
you know 10 years ago when we were first
building W from cloud a little bit more
than 10 years ago one of the big
questions was could we take the things
we developed on desktop computers all of
the Windows system capability all of the
kind of graphical user interface
capabilities we had on desktop computers
and could we use one of these trans
compilers to turn that all into weird
JavaScript code and have it run in the
browser browser thankfully we didn't try
to do that and I say thankfully because
while small pieces of that work even 10
years later to take sort of a full
application on a desktop system with all
of its connections into fonts and
operating system calls and all this kind
of thing and make that work in
JavaScript in a browser is still
infeasible will it remain infeasible
well not doesn't there's no of theorem
that it will remain INF feasible I will
say there are some issues because the
security model of browsers that sort of
says what happens in the browser stays
in the browser type thing and doesn't
leak out into your computer in general
without it being a very controlled kind
of kind of thing that model makes it
pretty difficult to access the kinds of
resources that operating systems usually
access like your file system and so on
in a transparent way so that's a that's
a kind of a a well you that's what
you've signed up for in your browser but
you know I think this question of
whether you can you know what you should
be running in the browser and uh you
know should you be running a wol from
language kernel in the browser well you
can run a wol from language kernel in
your operating system so in principle it
should be able to be run in the browser
but it's you know this is such a it's
sort of a complicated thing because
because another thing that could happen
is that you know people say oh it's you
know there's all these things they're
amazing python libraries well actually
they're not python libraries they're C++
libraries they just have a rapper that's
Python and just like things that you
know are written in wol from language
that the functions in wol from language
uh you know the insides of those
functions they might be W from language
code they might be C code there might
even be jav Java code or python code or
something like this to the user of wol
language it doesn't make make any
difference what's inside there and so so
it is with with a lot of these other
things that the what's inside you know
even if it was sort of a JavaScript
rapper that somehow ran in the browser
and it was really calling a piece of of
uh you know of C code that would be a
possible thing but for one problem which
is the security model of browsers which
means that a lot of that sort of raw I'm
just going to call the you know have the
CPU do these things isn't something that
browsers allow now if you said well I
don't worry about that I've I've signed
that piece of code I know that piece of
code is okay uh you know let it just
fall through to running directly in on
my computer uh Raw on on the computer
system then one could imagine that the
browser becomes essentially just a
portal to things that are happening sort
of Down Below in in the Raw operating
system of the computer so I think um and
and you know when you ask the
question okay so there's another
practical question which is in a browser
if you say well I'm going to implement
this thing in
JavaScript um well then the way that
works right now and again this is so
bizarre in terms of the history of
computing because you know this whole
question about does it run locally on a
computer does it run on a server what's
sort of happening in the whole world of
browsers is well there are things that
run on the server and then there are
things where they run inside the browser
but how do you make something run inside
the browser well unless you're
Distributing that code with okay with
with the browser somehow you have to
download the
code in that op in that session of the
browser to be able to run that thing so
now okay so now we get things like
browser plugins browser plugins were a
thing for quite a while where one time
you download a bunch of code and it's
kind of signed in some way you attach it
to your browser and then you can run
with that code in your browser but then
the makers of browsers for I think a
mixture of kind of commercial motivation
and uh and security concerns probably
with more weit on the first one um were
uh you know decided well this is
probably five years ago decided browser
plugins are a bad idea um let's uh you
know let's have it be the case that if
you want to run some in your browser it
must be code that you've downloaded
during that browser session so that
means that if you want for example you
know the full war from language kernel
that's pretty big there are sort of
minimized versions of it there are one
or 200 megabytes but still downloading
one or 200 megabytes just sort of in
that browser session is kind of a kind
of a
nuisance then there's a question well
does the browser cach these things that
gets into sort of complicated details of
software engineering and things that you
don't want to have to rely on in setting
the system up but could you imagine a
case actually sort of an interesting
idea to take the framework of a browser
like a Chromium browser uh browser
system or web kit or something like this
and sort of uh uh and sort of hollow out
some pieces of it and stick a war from
language kernel in there and have it be
something that can run in the framework
of the browser so to speak uh when when
you've decided this is the browser I'm
running I'm running my own special brows
browser that has access to other comput
other capabilities on my computer like
wol language and have that run inside
the browser locally it's sort of an
interesting idea hadn't hadn't actually
occurred to me maybe we should look at
trying to trying to do that but
um uh but I think you know there are
there are just a lot of weird sort of
computer security meets commercial
interests meets you know software
engineering kinds of constraints on just
what can run in browser
and plus the sort of flakiness component
that is if you're running you know if
you have a big stack of technology and I
mean you know it happens to me with some
regularity that that we will have
downloaded in fact in our wol from cloud
one of the limitations to us is browsers
choke you know we will download
something and it's perfect JavaScript
it's absolutely correct but it's somehow
too complicated for some poor browser
and the browser kind of Falls over and
dies and by the way I'm pretty sure we
still have all kinds of things in wolf
from cloud that um uh uh actually know
what browser you're using and say ah no
you know chrome doesn't do the handle
that very well you know if it's Firefox
is okay but if it's Chrome it's not okay
or whatever way around it is you know
let's not send that construct to this
particular browser because it's not
going to work properly and that that um
and and so you you know we've had those
constraints that that that goes to say
that you know people say oh JavaScript
and browsers it's kind of a universal
platform you can write something in
JavaScript to run on all browsers well
it's not true um I don't know how true
it is or isn't today I certainly know
that a few years ago that was a major
issue for us and a major issue in our
testing protocol of dealing with
multiple different browsers and the
different kinds of bugs you would get
from different failures to be able to
handle sort of the full deep spectrum of
of JavaScript
capabilities
uh let's
see yeah Yer is commenting on on where
is them to see user space code running
in kernel space yes yes yes no I mean
this is the
uh you so the future of computer
security is its own separate interesting
question I mean just to just to Riff on
that a little bit I mean to
me what is computer security about you
know you want your computer to do what
you want your computer to do and not
what you don't want your computer to do
but the issue is if you've got some
quotes smart something or other whether
it's a smart firewall or a smart this
that or the other as soon as you say
it's smart it's
probably going to be doing things that
weren't that are sort of beyond what you
immediately imagined it might do so to
speak and so that means that it
uh it's and the question is well so how
far can it go and this is kind of the
and and when people try to attack your
computer well as's a whole collection of
of attacking the humans by by you know
social engineering and fishing and
things like this but let's put that
aside if you're trying to attack sort of
the the computer itself what you're
typically trying to do is to get the
computer to do something that it wasn't
intended to do and as soon as you have
program systems that are quote smart so
they're able to do lots of kinds of
things there is the potential for
somebody to be able to get them to do a
thing that they weren't supposed to do
and so there's a bit of a trade-off to
you know just how smart do you want
things these things to be and and how do
you then guarantee how do you check that
the thing can never ever do the thing
you didn't want it to do some kinds of
things you don't want it to do are
obvious like Scribble on your files that
might be a definite thing where you
could say Noe we don't want it to do
that and we can essentially prove a
theorem that it can't do that but it can
often be a lot more subtle than that I
mean the the um uh and so you know I
think sort of the way to think about it
is it's it's one of these trade-offs and
it's a trade-off deeply related to
questions about AI ethics where the
issue is you know how much do we want
the AIS to be able to smartly do
interesting things for us versus how
much do we want to be able to guarantee
that they only do the things we want
them to do and that's a that's you know
that's a trade-off there and I think
when it comes to some of these questions
about uh sort of security of of doing
this or that
thing you know the the more you want to
have happen and particularly have happen
automatically the more difficult it is
to sort of secure all that stuff but to
some extent the more you can Define what
it is that you really don't want to have
happen the easier it is to potentially
prove that that can't
happen um I should
probably uh wrap up soon here um but
maybe one
more question if I can see
something reasonably short okay uh let's
try this one um
Peter asks is llm the wrong direction
for
AI uh it's a good direction it's not the
only possible Direction I mean it
depends a little bit what one means by
AI if one means by AI sort of using
computation to automate things there are
many directions for that llms are really
trying to essentially replicate
humanlike sort of output so specifically
language you know given some number of
billions of web pages that you can read
can you train a neuronet to produce
language that is sort of typical of what
you would find on those web pages and
then do the same kinds of things for
images and and videos and the
connections between images and videos
and and sound and and language and so on
can you essentially make something that
sort of replicates typical human
activity in these areas and that given a
oh you got this piece of text so far how
would that typically continue if it were
to be done by humans there's a lot of
use cases where that's a worthwhile
thing to do and what's been interesting
with llms in in recent times is what
started as a pure kind of idea of can
you continue the text from where it left
off or can you fill in a blank in the
text with the most likely thing for that
to be filled in as that that notion of
just you know text completion turns out
when you do that well enough there are
many other use cases that don't really
look much like text completion that can
still be reached from that function of
text completion so although I don't
think it's kind of a universal function
I don't think that's the only thing that
uh sort of it's useful to have computers
do by any means there's lots of you know
purely computational things that one
wants computers to do that aren't kind
of these humanlike activities it's still
it's it's a broader thing than we had
expected in terms
of whether even for that function of you
know write plausible text and so on is
the specific architecture of llms as it
is today the thing that will survive n
years in the future uh I don't think it
should it might in fact because the way
that things developed technologically is
some particular method gets invented and
then then everything is optimized
engineering rised around the method that
was invented so this happened with uh
floating Point numbers it happened to
some extent with linear algebra on
computers you you build certain
algorithms and then or certain methods
certain ways of representing data and so
on and then sort of the the big
engineering stack of all the special
purpose hardware and all this kind of
thing gets built to service that that
particular way of doing things so even
if there was a better way of doing
things it would be hard to reach from
where you are because there's so much
investment and so much capability that's
been built up in the particular way of
doing things that already existed that
you never really change from that I mean
that's the story of Technology
throughout history that that that that
tends to happen that you get a solution
that might not be the theoretical
Optimum but by the time you've had this
whole stack of engineering detail built
on it it becomes the practical optimal
thing to do so but you know in terms of
the specifics of llms I think one of the
things that certainly should happen is
well there several things I mean one is
taking the knowledge component of llms
and dropping it out of the linguistic
component you know have the llm call W
from language or W from alpha to get
actual specific knowledge to do actual
specific computations don't try to
Cobble that together with pieces of
neural net weights because it's a very
very inefficient way to do things that
ultimately won't work so that's one
thing we don't yet know how to do it
really we know how to get an llm with
difficulty to call tools to perform
particular actions we don't really know
how to do this finer grain just don't
worry about having knowledge in the llm
have that all in an external system have
the llm be a pure linguistic interface
that's one thing I think will will
change another thing is llms encode data
in real numbers they encoded in let's
say 32-bit numbers um where sort of you
are encoding somehow in some mysterious
way the fact that uh you know I don't
know that the typicals of the world
probably know a little bit about me the
fact that you know I was born in such
and such a year that that year is
probably encoded maybe it'll maybe it'll
make it up some of the time but that
year is encoded ultimately in some high
order bit of some whole collection of
different neural weights in the neural
net it's a very bizarre way to encode a
number like that but also the the thing
that's been done in in current neural
Nets is let's say you have 100 billion
artificial neurons weights for the
neural Nets that's 100 billion numbers
each 32 bits long so there's a question
do you need to do it that way or could
you have a
trillion numbers that are each just two
bits could you essentially
distribute not just have all these
different weights but kind of shatter
the weights into lots of different
separated uh more discrete kinds of
components so let me give an analogy if
you're doing fluid dynamics it seems
like I often use fluid dynamics as an
analogy but if you're doing fluid
dynamics one thing you can do is you
have this fluid and you imagine the
fluid has a certain velocity at
different positions you imagine taking
this velocity field with all these
different velocities
as as and taking little lumps of fluid
and saying this lump of fluid has a
velocity going that way this lump has a
velocity going that way and then solving
some whole complicated set of equations
relating to those that the the relations
between the velocities at different
positions okay that's plan a plan B
which something I kind of invented in
the 1980s is imagine that you can
idealize this fluid to something which
is just a bunch of completely discrete
sort of digital atoms where you just
have a grid of of of cells and at each
cell you either have a sort of a
molecule going this in this in Direction
one or Direction two there's no real
number that there it's saying the
velocity is
73482 the velocity is either zero or one
basically well it turns out that you can
uh if you aggregate that up and it's the
same way that sort of uh things actually
work in physics and it's the same way
that things work in our in our physics
project models
that you're you're kind of you're
Distributing the information about these
molecules sort of to lots of different
idealized molecules rather than
collecting them together and saying
there's this velocity field represented
by real numbers so you can imagine doing
the same thing with the neets instead of
encoding the information in sort of
centralized real numbers and they're not
that centralized because you might have
a 100 billion of them but instead of
packing things into real numbers you're
Distributing the information across
collections of bits and there's no
numbers involved now we don't yet know
how to deal with that because the
training of neural Nets is right now
very deeply connected to the way we do
things with Calculus and with small
changes of numbers and kind of taking
derivatives and things like this so we
don't know how to do it to take to sort
of distribute the information across
things that aren't really numbers
they're just bits so to speak but that
my guess is if we could do that then
with current computer hardware we would
have much faster neural Nets or neural
net like things now if special Hardware
is built and it is being built that
deals with neural Nets as they are
configured today that might not be true
another thing is that the way neural
Nets work we have kind of the you know
you train a neural net you go to all
this effort you train it then it's like
here's the train neural net now go and
run it a billion times or whatever and
and now have everybody just you know
type things to their favorite l m um
many times over and that llm is not
incrementally learning that llm at best
is being kind of fine-tuned but even
that isn't isn't actually happening in
practice uh then the question is but for
human brains for example it seems to be
the case that we're always learning we
don't go through I mean some people
maybe take that point of view about
their lives that they go through the
training period during the education and
then they learn no more that's kind of a
shame but realistically we learn
continuously
from things that happen we're not just
like train first do later we're kind of
train and do at the same time and that's
something that current neural Nets we
don't have a way to do that that's
surely a Coming Attraction we just don't
know how to do it and you know if you
look at the history of these things it's
actually kind of shocking how how old a
lot of the ideas are that show up in in
llms the engineering details are new and
the fact that the engineering worked and
that gives this huge sort of uh uh kind
of effect of then you can do much more
than you're confident to do things but
you know the core ideas of neural Nets
state from the 1940s a lot of detailed
things about reinforcement learning and
so on that's a kind of control theory
story that dates from actually not sure
when 1950s 1960s I think um and uh and a
lot of a lot of these different ideas
about about how to do things are
actually surprisingly old it took
but they only kind of came together and
came to fruition very
recently and so you know there's a
question of do you need fundamentally
new ideas maybe there are other ideas
and there certainly have been other
ideas about constructing things like
neuron Nets that have existed over the
years and okay the field of neural nets
for for decades was one of these fields
where nobody knew what was going to
happen with it it was just like it was
out there and some people were working
on it a few things were useful
applications but it wasn't really a
great shining you know sparkly kind of
thing and then suddenly it started to
work in 2012 and then more recently with
llms and so on but there are other kinds
of things that have been used for
machine learning whether it's you know
support Vector machines or
self-organizing Maps or all these kinds
of things these are not neural Nets and
but those techniques got a certain
distance but they never had that kind of
moment of breakthrough that neural Nets
had in 2012 and in
2022 so it uh it's not self-evident that
those things can't have a breakthrough
moment and that they can't be very
different architectures for doing
machine learning that will have
breakthroughs it's it's really a
question of you know why why neural Nets
broke through and it wasn't one of these
other methods I don't think we know yet
and could those other methods break
through and give us things we didn't
expect like large language models and
their success we didn't expect that in
terms of the kind of overall trajectory
of neural Nets and maybe there's some
other kind of task that will be done
spectacularly by one of these other
machine learning methods if only it
could have its breakthrough moment and
you know as is usual in the in the
history of Science and Technology once
something works everybody rushes to the
thing that works and usually that means
even if there was something else which
could have been the runner up that maybe
the later thing that works it tends to
get sort of starved of oxygen because
everybody's rushed off to the other to
the thing that's starting to work so on
the other hand and you know if you're
working on the thing that's working well
then you're probably going to make stuff
that works fairly quickly if you're
working on the thing that hasn't yet
worked it might be 20 years it might be
a 100 years before that starts to work
or it might never work um it's kind of
much more of a
risk all right I think I need to um uh
go and uh to my day job here but thank
you for a bunch of interesting questions
as usual and I see a bunch more that are
going to be saved up for another time so
thanks very much and uh bye for
now